it's and it's a deep question because it
isn't even obvious whether the question
are there things you should
value is a reasonable question
or that it can be reasonably answered
the thing i can tell you about that
that's most closely allied with my own
experience
i don't mean personal experience but say
experience as a clinician is that
aimless people are in real trouble
now i don't necessarily know why that is
and i don't necessarily know
what that means for what your aim should
be
but i've certainly seen for example like
if you had to make a choice which all of
you will in the next five years or so
between pursuing
something like diligently and
establishing a fixed identity because of
that
or remaining bereft of choice and
drifting
i i can tell you that if you drift by
the time you're 30 you're going to be
one miserable person
now i'm not sure why that is exactly and
i'm not exactly sure that that
necessarily means that
picking something and sticking to it
which is a form of apprenticeship is
better than drifting
it depends on what you mean by better
but i can tell you that
not catalyzing an identity seems to be a
mistake
and it's a fatal mistake by the time
you're 40.
it's very very difficult to recover from
it at that point because
you're not young anymore at that point
and if you try to catalyze an identity
at that time which
sometimes can happen you're competing
with all these like young shiny people
and it's not
who are much more full of potential from
the perspective of an employer for
example
than you are it gets pretty dismal